.
RoseAnne Archibald, une cheffe
de l'Ontario, promet de faire
la lumière dans le dossier
des pensionnats.
Julie-Anne Lapointe.
- Dans la jeune vingtaine et
déjà, elle traçait le début
de son parcours vers la scène
fédérale, prête à lutter pour
le droit des Autochtones.
- Une trentaine d'années de
militantisme qui ont permis
à RoseAnne Archibald de briser
le plafond de verre.
- La cheffe de l'Ontario devient
la première femme à la tête
de l'Assemblée
des Premières Nations.
- Une victoire pour toutes
les femmes et un symbole
d'espoir pour celles aux grandes
ambitions.
MICHÈLE AUDETTE, Enquête, femmes
autochtones assassinées
- J'ai été sollicitée pour
le national, et j'avais toujours
cette crainte-là : Ah! non,
on n'est pas prêt, on n'est pas
prêt et c'est sûr, dans mes
petites prières ce matin, je me
disais : hi! Je suis fière,
elle, elle a osé.
- RoseAnne Archibald incarne
un désir de renouveau
en ces temps troubles.
LYNNE GROULX, dg, Asso.
des femmes autochtones du Canada
- C'est vraiment un temps
difficile, alors là, je pense
que la communauté, elle a dit :
"Mais là, on va peut-être
prendre une perspective
différente, on essaie avec
une femme qui est très forte".
- Au sommet de sa liste
de priorités : la recherche
des sites d'anciens pensionnats
pour Autochtones.
- Au-delà des enjeux qui ont
fait les manchettes
ces dernières semaines, d'autres
problèmes perdurent dans
les communautés autochtones :
problèmes d'eau potable, racisme
dans le système de santé,
des défis liés aux changements
climatiques. La nouvelle cheffe
s'est dotée d'un plan de 100
jours pour y apporter des pistes
de solutions.
ROBERT FALCON OUELETTE,
anthropologue, Centre Pearson
- C'est beaucoup de travail,
il faut qu'elle soit à la tête
quasiment d'un mini gouvernement
sans les pouvoirs
d'un gouvernement.
- Les attentes des communautés
sont grandes.
À peine élue, la nouvelle
leader doit déjà se défendre
face aux critiques.
L'Assemblée des Premières
Nations a lancé une enquête
à son sujet sur des allégations
d'intimidation et
de harcèlement, un rapport
interne obtenu par CBC ne révèle
aucun détail sur l'affaire.
- "Il n'y a jamais eu de plainte
officielle", dit-elle, aucune
rencontre pour discuter
de ce rapport.
- Maintenant élue,
RoseAnne Archibald doit
rassembler les troupes.
Seulement 50 % des chefs
avaient voté pour elle même
après le 5e tour de scrutin.
- Madame Archibald doit parler
à tout le monde, mais de dire
de rassembler tout le monde,
ca va être à nous aussi
de marcher à côté d'elle
puis de la soutenir.
- La nouvelle cheffe assure que
son expérience politique
lui permettra de rallier
les membres. Une image d'une
assemblée forte et unie qui sera
essentielle pour pousser
le gouvernement à respecter
ses engagements envers
les Premières nations.
Ici Julie-Anne.